أجنبية
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
أسمع أن الملك تشارلز هو ملكك الذي
لا شك فيه،
ولهذا السبب يا جميع الذين سآتي اليوم
لتأدية إجلالكم وخدمتكم،
هل أنتم على استعداد لفعل الشيء نفسه، هل
تعدون وتقسمون رسميًا؟
تحكم شعوب المملكة المتحدة
لبريطانيا العظمى وأيرلندا الشمالية
ممالكك الأخرى والأقاليم التابعة
لأي منهم تنتمي أو تتعلق
وفقًا لقوانينهم وعاداتهم،
لقد وعدتها رسميًا أن تفعل
[موسيقى]
تتلقى كل هذا
تحت الصليب
[  موسيقى]
أوه [
موسيقى]
أنقذ الله الملك
في ويلز، أتعهد بالولاء لك
والإيمان والحقيقة، وسأتحمل لك
رغبتي في تقديم دعمهم للقيام بذلك
مع لحظة من التأمل الخاص
من خلال الانضمام إلى قول حفظ الله الملك
تشارلز في  النهاية
أو لأولئك الذين لديهم الكلمات التي أمامهم
ليقرأوها بالكامل،
أتمنى أن تمتلئ خادمتك كاميلا التي ترتدي هذا
التاج بنعمتك الوفيرة [
موسيقى]
شكرًا لك [
موسيقى] [
تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
أجنبي أجنبي أجنبي